well i see we have a full house so we
can
take the liberty of starting a minute or
two before the traditional 4 10.
my name is dick carp i'm the director of
the simons institute and
i'm happy to welcome you to the second
simon's institute open lecture of of
this semester
and we're delighted to have professor
emmanuel candes as our speaker
emanuel did his undergraduate work at
the cold polytechnique in paris
he then got his doctorate in statistics
at stanford
in 1998 remained there for a couple of
years and then
moved to cal tech where he
was on the faculty until 2006 when he
returned to
stanford where he is now a professor of
statistics mathematics and
electrical engineering
he's very famous for his
work in compressive sensing
and with applications to many areas
of signal processing imaging inverse
problems
information theory in general optics
chemistry
it's an area that has really diverse
connections which makes his work
especially interesting emanuel was
given the waterman prize in 2006
this is an annual award for the most
outstanding
scientist under the age of 35 in the
united states so it's a very important
recognition of his work
he also holds the simon
simon's professorship of the barnum
simons professorship
at stanford that's part of a program
called math plus
x where the simons foundation recognizes
outstanding researchers who bridge
between mathematics and
some application area and
today emanuel is going to tell us about
the effectiveness of convex programming
in the information and physical sciences
okay thank you richard for this very fun
introduction
uh it is a pleasure to give this open
lecture and i'd like to thank the
directors of the institute for inviting
me
a few years ago we also beat at stanford
for the simon's institute
we were not successful but
retrospectively it's a very good idea i
think because then we can come to your
beautiful campus enjoy your beautiful
center
without even having to run it so
it's just great it's a pleasure to be
here really so the topic of this lecture
is uh the interplay between convex
programming
and the information and physical
sciences and to be
honest with you i don't have the skills
nor the competence to give you a grand
view
of the interplay between these exciting
disciplines
so i'm going to limit myself to tell you
just three stories
and so um you know three stories
to quote from steve jobs that's it no
big deal just three stories from my
recent work
and that's all we're gonna do now these
stories are all connected
uh through a theme first of course the
use of convex
programming but also the fact that we
wish to recover
signals or objects or data matrices from
what appear to be incomplete sets of
data
and so in story number one we're going
to miss the phase of an image of
interest
this is a phase retrieval problem in
story number two we're going to miss
many samples from a large data matrix of
interest
and in story number three we're going to
be interested in recovering a broadband
signal but the problem is the completely
high end part of the frequency spectrum
is completely missing
so the fact that we have all this
missingness makes
signal recovery difficult yet
and to me this is a bit of a surprise
what we'll see
that very simple convex ideas usually
always
not always return the right answer
okay so i want to talk about the first
story which is about phase retrieval
and before i get started i just want to
mention that this is work with
jonina eldar zhaodongli thomas trummer
and vladislav
noporoninsky who used to be a graduate
student at berkeley and now at mit
okay so what is the phase retrieval
problem it has its origin in x-ray
crystallography
and x-ray crystallography as everybody
knows is a method for determining the
atomic structure within a crystal
and it works roughly as follows so
you've got a crystal of interest let's
say
indicated by something like this or or
more
simply like this what you do is you
strike x-rays onto this crystal
and then those x-rays get diffracted
right so you have a
an x-ray tube that generates there you
collimate the x-rays they strike the
crystal
then the crystal diffracts the rays and
so you're going to
get a pattern and you call so-called
diffraction pattern
and then you you record um the amp
the intensity of the diffracted rate
okay so we're discussing here are very
important areas of science if you look
at
the number of normal prices awarded
around x-ray crystallography it's at
least
10 and it may not be over
okay just to give you a sense this is an
open lecture so
a sense of the importance of x-ray
imaging
this is of course a technique that was
used to
discover the double helix of the dna
which arguably may be the most important
scientific discovery after world war ii
and so franklin had make exquisite
x-ray photographs and then uh i click in
watson
use this exquisite photograph to
interfere on this
double helix structure okay
so what is the missing phase problem uh
we in physics we have to deal with the
fact that detectors
can only record intensities of
distracted rays
you have magnitude measurements only you
cannot sense the phase of the optical
field only
its intensity and so mathematically
speaking because when you do x-ray
imaging you're immediately in the far
field so i'm going to skip the details
because
i want to give you three stories so
we're going to keep the mathematical
details to a bare minimum
but roughly what happens when you go and
collect x-ray data
what happens is you have the object of
interest which is here an image of two
variables t1 and t2
the optical field here is simply the
fourier transform
of of the object that you wish to
recover but i cannot measure its intense
its phase i can only measure its
intensity and so i just get to see the
modulus
squared of the electrical field i cannot
see the phase and now
the phase retrieval problem is an
inversion problem which is a century-old
problem
extremely important problem in the
physical sciences is how can we cover
the phase
or equivalent as a signal from from the
modulus of its fourier transform
and of course this seems extremely
imposed because while you can impute any
phase and invert so
we're going to have to talk about this
okay so just to show you uh
importance of phase information we have
two gentlemen the 43rd
and 44th president of the united states
and what i did is i computed the fourier
transform and here they are
and now what i did in a
you know in a i i kept the magnitude
of the 44th president but i impute the
swa the phase of the 43rd and vice versa
so i keep the magnitude but i swap the
face
and then i invert the fourier transform
i get something like that and so what we
can see from this sim call experiment
is that whatever physicist knows that
the phase encodes most of the
information there is very little in the
magnitude about the object
you care about so missing the phase is
really about proposition
okay so x-ray imaging is a very active
area of research
this is the first x-ray photograph ever
taken by wilhelm
wangan of course the first nobel prize
for physics discovered the existence of
x-rays
what you see here is the hand of his
wife
with her wedding band i think and
now you see that of course people are
trying to image complicated stuff
with x-rays and for example
this is a kind of picture that people
are trying to to produce now
so x-ray imaging is a very exciting area
of research
that makes the cover of the most
exciting magazines such as nature
for example at slack at stanford there
is a ultra-short x-ray pulses
that are used to try to image large
protein complexes
and so what you've got is you've got you
know large protein complexes that fall
into in front of an x-ray beam
which is very short direction high
energy and so what you do is you're
blasting this molecule with this
x-ray beam and so you collect the
diffraction pattern just before the
molecule explodes and out of these
diffraction patterns
you want to recover 3d structure
okay all right so this is a mass
or discrete mass center so let's talk a
little bit about the mathematics
of phase retrieval so mathematically if
i think about my object and i know it's
i'm taking a little bit of liberty where
it's reality but
if i think about an object as being comp
discrete
so this quicktime or discrete space so
i've got an object which is in cn and
yes we can extend the results as a
continuous world and i'm not going to
talk about it today
so i just want to keep things simple so
there's an object which is
the picture of interest let's say the
pixelized image of interest
that has leaves in cn so i have n pixels
and i've got a magnitude and a face
and when i do go through this kind of
measurement process that we've just
described what i've got is i've got
quadratic equations
about the object of interest so that is
that i take my object my unknown object
i
dot product with waveforms ak so if ak
is a
this is exactly the experiment i
described i'm going to see use a fourier
transform
but you cannot see the phase so it just
sees the square modulus
okay so the phase retrieval problem
mathematically it's very very simply
stated
is the following problem let's find an
object x which is compatible
with this quadratic equation so it's
really the solution to
solving quadratic equations
now solving quadratic equation is np
hard in general
i guess if you can show that you can
solve any system of quadratic equations
then then it says a lot about complexity
classes
let me show you a little bit uh what
happens so suppose you're in the real
world so everything is real valued
well you would like to see ax but that
you don't see ax you see absolute value
of
x you don't see the sign so when i take
a linear measurement after linear
measurement i would know that i'm on
this plane or this plane but now i don't
know the sign so i don't know on which
planes i am
and then i take another measurements and
again there's this ambiguity i never
know on which
plane i am it's a pair of symmetric
planes
and i continue the data collection okay
and i continue and i continue
and in the end i've got these polytopes
with exponentially many vertices i know
the solution is one of these vertices
but i have
really don't know which one and i think
that there is no algorithm known today
that would work better or
essentially find them and you write all
vertices and find the correct one
now if you over the the real life
which is that now things takes place in
are complex valued
then things are even more complicated
because now instead of having pairs of
planes
when i give you a a dot x squared equals
something now i'm just talking about an
algebraic surface
okay and so now if we're doing complex
valued stuff it's more complicated
because each time i give you a
measurement
you know that you're on an algebraic
surface and now you've got
lots of algebraic surfaces and you have
to find their intersection
and that is extremely hard okay so to go
back to
my previous slide it's known to be np
hard in general now it has not stopped
physicists of course to try to find
it's such an important problem that
you've got to find solutions
and so there was wonderful work by
hartman and carly who developed
essentially bayesian methods
using prior information about what is it
that we should cover it's a crystal
after all
um that you'd make very usef very
specific prior
use very specific prior information
about what is it that we're looking for
and they were awarded the nobel prize
for their face retrieval library
in 85. people don't really use it these
days
people use instead maybe i'm not going
to
tell you what it is but they use the
gersch-saxon algorithm which is an
iterative
algorithm that projects in data space
projecting in physical uh in physical
space projecting data space and so on
iteratively
that is not known to converge and when
you run it on real data sometimes it
works well
and sometimes it does not and the
literature is full of issues with this
stuff
okay all right so this is our phase
retrieval problem
no phase what are we going to do okay so
we're going to
propose we need to bring convexity in
this so now of course it's not a convex
problem of course as you can see
the feasible set is absolutely not
convex so we're going to convexify it
and the way we're going to do this is
we're going to use a technique
where we're going to replace the unknown
object little x the signal
by a matrix capital x
okay so now i want to think about
capital x as a matrix x x star so it's a
rank 1 matrix
that happens to be positive
semi-definite
okay and now the key observation is
something like this is
when i take a quadratic measurement
about little x
it is exactly the same as taking a
literal measurement about xx star like
there's a little bit of algebra that
is trivial it's undergraduate level
right so
basically what this is is if i have my
uh my unknown xx star
then whenever i show you quadratic
information about x
it is the same as giving you the dot
product between the matrix x star
and the rank one matrix which happens to
be a k a k star
okay so what this kind of lifting does
to kind of
take the problem little on objects and
mapping into the space of positive
semi-definite matrices
it makes the measurement linear all of a
sudden
okay everybody's with me yeah
okay all right so so we're going to take
this point of view
and so in this world what is the
um phase retrieval problem it's very
simply stated
when i think about it this way it's an
equivalent viewpoint
what i have to do then is i have to find
a matrix capital x
whose linear measurements are the data
point i collected in the lab
it's positive semi-definite but i don't
forget that this matrix is xx star
so it has rank one okay and so since
there is a rank one solution
the phase retrieval problem can be cast
as follows
is simply the problem of minimizing the
rank of a matrix subject to
a section of the positive semi-definite
code
okay so when i've done this i've not
done anything the problem is still np
hard
i just look at it differently
all right so now most of you know what's
coming that well we have this rank
constraint that is not friendly
so we're going to get rid of it and get
and and and get something friendly
instead
and so the phase lift that we propose
with jonina thomas and vlad
is this following it's like let's remove
this rank constraint
and let's do instead the following let's
minimize the trace of x
which is really a proxy for the rank so
for those of you who know a little bit
about sparse signal recovery
the trace is the sum of singular values
and the rank is the number of non-zero
singular values and so it's really
the equivalent of l1 in the matrix world
so we just do is we minimize the trace
of x subject to
the trace of a k x is b k and x and so
now i'm looking at something which is
an optimization program which is
actually completely tractable it's a
convex
optimization program in fact it's a
special class
of convex optimization program it's an
it's an sdp so this is a
class a special class of convex programs
for which we have good theory good
algorithms and so on
and so all i've done is i've replaced
the rank
which is not tractable by its convex
proxy
which is a trace okay so this is a
convex proxy for the rank
right that's a facelift relaxation
okay so do we have people who don't know
what is a semi-definite program
maybe i'm not going to explain what it
is just think about it something that
all of a sudden is
amenable to computations like it's i can
i can think and in fact
since we kind of introduced this
formulation there's lots of people who
have proposed algorithm for solving this
fairly efficiently
okay so i'm going to skip that and so
now something a bit strange happens
suppose i have a thousand
unknowns so suppose x is of dimension
one thousand maybe i have four thousand
equations
so now i was over determined in some
sense right i had more equations than
unknowns
now they're not solvable but i have more
equation than unknowns
so i was over determined in some sense
and now i'm completely underdetermined
because now i've got the number of
unknowns
unknown variables is x now i've lifted
everything so now the number of equation
unknowns is n squared so it's a million
unknowns and i still have only four
thousand equations
so i've went from a completely under the
overdetermined
to completely underdetermined things and
so maybe i think things
maybe things are terrible now because
now i'm completely under the term
okay now
this of course to people working in
computer science
reminds you of the relaxation of
quadratic constraints qps
okay so uh introduced by shor in 87
uh where he showed a lower bound on non
that you could use convex relaxations to
get
lower bounds on non-complex quadratic
optimization problems
of course in the theory uh in the
literature on theory of
computer science there is this
extraordinary papers of germans and
williamsons
where there's a relaxation of max cut
and this looks similar to
max cut and then uh of course there's a
lot of work about stuff like this so if
you look at the book of ben
talanimirovsky
you'll see a whole section on on convex
relaxations of
quadratic constrained qps now what is a
bit strange here is that to kind of do
this in the phase retrieval it's a bit
first of all it's a relaxation is a bit
different from what people do
but second it's a bit strange to us that
this kind of relaxation
was never considered in the case of
phase retrievals and problem like
in the in the physical sciences okay
but of course in theory of computer
science people have been trained to
think about it
along these lines okay so now
is this a good relaxation so what can we
say about this relaxation so
again i've got these quadratic equations
and let's say that i want to solve a
generic system of quadratic equations
using this approach and when i say a
generic system
i'm going to assume just because i want
to keep it simple
that well i have generic random
quadratic equations to solve
and so what i'm going to say is that the
a's they are uniformly sampled on the
sphere
right so the rows of the matrix a if you
will are uniform on the sphere
there is no preferred orientation
okay and we're going to try to solve
this by
by the the facelift approach
okay and there is this result uh
which we have established with
vlad and thomas and then later we find
with zhaodong
which says something a bit strange
it said that if i have a number of
quadratic equations
which is on the same order as the number
of unknowns
n then with very high probability in
fact the probability of failure is
exponentially small
in the number of quadratic equations i
can solve all
phase retrieval problems
by the approach i've seen and in fact
it's simpler than what i've just told
you
because what the theorem says is that
when i look at my feasible set
the set of matrices which are compatible
with the measurements i have taken
and are positively semi-definite it
reduces to a single point which is xx
star
so all i need to show to do to solve the
phase retrieval problem
from a number of equations which is
exactly the same
on the same order of magnitude as the
number of unknowns
is to solve a feasibility problem i just
need to find a data matrix x
which is in the space of the measurement
compatible with the measurement and it's
positive semi-definite that's all i've
got to do
i need to solve a feasibility problem
nothing else
now when i first discussed this result
well there was some skepticism that it
could be true
because it goes a bit against intuition
first of all let me just say that the
number of measurements you need is at
least four n times minus two otherwise
this mapping is not injective okay
that's a result of editing and his
colleagues
and the reason is there was a bit of
skepticism because well obviously
there's a dimension mismatch
right so if you have very few equations
and how can have a space of enormous
dimension intersect the positive
semi-defined cone which is a very fat
thing
on only a single point how is this
possible because the pictures that
everybody has in mind at least the
people we talked to at the beginning
was something like this i've got the
positive semi-definite cone which is
represented by the inside of this body
right so this is a set of two by two
matrices that are positive semi-definite
so in x y z it would be the inside
of this body now i have an enormously
dimensional
of an affine subspace of enormously high
dimension
and what the theorem says is that they
actually intersect in only one point
which is xx star so obviously there's
something wrong with this picture
so what is wrong with the picture is
that it's
the world does not look like this in
high dimensions
and so i don't know how to draw a
correct picture because now we have to
deal with high dimensional phenomena
and so i'm just going to tell you what
is in my mind and we'll see what i'm
successful in
in in communicating
the only thing i know really
so now what you do is you take a matrix
which is xx star it's a point in a very
high dimensional space
and now i'm trying to perturb it
now the perturbation to be feasible
needs to be positive semi-definite
now if i take a rank 1 matrix and i
perturb it by adding a symmetric matrix
and i say
add an arbitrary symmetric matrix do you
maintain positive similar fitness no
because
you know you had one positive
eigenvalues all the other one was zero
you add something symmetric so some
eigenvalues will become negative
so by moving in this direction you will
not maintain positive semi-definiteness
take another perturbation you will not
maintain positive
definiteness and so on right so if the
almost all perturbations you can think
of
will take you outside of the positive
semi-definite cone
so the picture i've got is that really
the positive semi-definite cone
around a rank one object is
extraordinarily sharp
so it looks like this right so i've got
xx star
and then the set of feasible directions
is extremely narrow
and now i take a very large
i find subspace that has to go through
this point and i say
where is it going to intersect the
positive semi-definite cone and it's
going to intersect in only one point
which is this point right and so the
reason the
the the phase retrieval by semi-definite
programming works
is because the positive semi-definite
cone is extremely sharp
around low rank objects
okay all right
so well you'd say what is my model have
to do with physics
because i assume that the equations were
random
in fact you can extend this work and now
this is john work with steel zhao dong
and maddie salt and alcotabi
where we should well what you could do
to do the phase retrieval
is to do something like this you shine
your x-ray source on your molecule and
then you encode it
by putting a face plate so this is like
a binary mask
if you will and then you let the thing
diffract each time you change your mask
over here a few times
you collect a few diffraction patterns
now you have quadratic equations
that are now physically realistic
and what the theory says is that this
works as well
okay so this works not only for
idealized models but also for things
that are a bit close to
what you might be interested in in
practice
okay all right so when you do this on on
data
it works reasonably well
so so what we did is we implemented code
and stuff to
solve the phase retrieval problem in
this setup by just finding a feasible
okay and so in blue here you see a
a signal and in red you see the
reconstruction
and you see that they're exactly on top
of each other because the semi-definite
program gives you exactly the same
answer and since it i make no assumption
about the signal it doesn't matter
whether the signal is kind of smooth
like this
or random like this it really doesn't
matter because it's all about
the encoding process and not about the
input
and so what you see in practice is that
typically
we have algo well when you implement the
semi-definite programming idea
so if you have a signal with n
components
and blocks of information which is
complex valued so you have really two n
unknowns
if you give me six n measurements that's
enough
right so i can recover or we can recover
arbitrary signals from about with 2n
unknowns from about
six diffraction patterns
you need at least four and with six this
seems to work
okay now the good thing about convex
programming which is a theme that i'm
gonna silence a little bit in this
lecture
is that well it's a model free method so
now in fact in real life
uh the data is not going to be exactly x
dot ak because you're going to have
noise so you're going to have let's say
a poisson statistic
and so what you say is well in general
what i'm going to do is i'm not going to
solve the feasibility problem i'm going
to try to find a point
a matrix x which is as close to b as
possible
in some sense by maybe perhaps
maximizing the log likelihood or do
things like that
subject to x positive semi-definite if
you get a solution
x which is not rank one just take its
rank one solution
and that's your signal and the
statistical theory would say something
like
well you can't really do better than
this in
really i mean there's if you do this
then there's no method that can
essentially work much better than this
okay all right so the the thing is that
maybe
i'm going to not talk to you about the
statistical theory i think what is
convenient with convex programming is
when when you have
approximate data noise and so on it goes
through the same machinery
and you get you get a stable recovery
meaningful results
this is a very boring plot but we were
very happy when we saw it
it's very very boring because what it
shows it shows a relative mean square
there
in db so on a log scale versus a signal
to noise ratio on a log scale
and what we see is as a signal to noise
ratio increases the mean squared error
decreases in a very predictable fashion
okay and so what that's saying is each
time your signal
the noise level goes down then the
relative msc goes down
and so what you have is you have the
kind of plots you would get if you were
to solve
a well posed least squares problem okay
so it has
even though the the generation mechanism
you don't have a linear model
even though you have a absolutely
non-linear reconstruction method
everything behaves as if you were
solving a well-posed
discourse problem okay
and so you can apply this to real data
and we have
uh courtesy of stefano marcozzini at lbl
and so so you get you can get pictures
of gold balls if you want to
all right okay so that was my
story number one should i take questions
about story number one now or the annual
yes
yeah as long as i've got quadratic
equations that are sufficiently
randomized to some extent
you can uh you can yeah of course yeah
yeah i mean there is a theory
um speaking of computer science what's
the status of uh
implementation of this you know and the
scalability
of what um right so this i will answer
at the end
because i think this is a theme that
we're going to see several times
so yeah okay so let's me
now move on to story number two uh er
still connected with a missing data
problem
and now it's work with ima and john
wright and they are a wonderful computer
scientist
john is at columbia and he is at
microsoft research in beijing
okay so we're going to talk about a
completely different problem now
and uh the problem is inspired by now
not physics but problems in data
analysis
and i'll tell you where it's coming from
in a minute but right now the problem is
as follows
there's a data matrix m that you get to
c as a statistician
which is the sum of uh of a matrix l
which is low rank
which is essentially picturely
represented by
something like this and the sparse
matrix which is something like this
right so the lowering part is not
observed
and the sparse part is not observed what
you get to see is
the sum of the two
okay and the question that we would like
to ask is can we recover
l and s accurately and again it seems
that we have a terribly missing data
problem
well how many unknowns do i have well
two times the number of entries
how many equations do i have well the
number of entries
it seems like it's not right
okay now why do we care about this
at least my motivation and you'll see
that there was another team working on
this
completely different motivation my
motivation was
robust pca so
everybody knows what is principal
component analysis we have
a data matrix this is point number one
point number two point number three so
we have columns
in a matrix and we like to reduce
dimensions so we assume that these
columns
lie near a low dimensional subspace
and so if i can only plot in the planes
if these columns were lying near a
one-dimensional subspace
where i were to plot them it would look
something like this
and so if i run pca i would get
the low dimensional structure very very
well
but now suppose that maybe there is a
corruption point in this data matrix
there is one entry that has been on
purpose
or maybe not on purpose incorrectly
recorded
right so this point that was plotted
here in blue
because this entry is incorrectly
recorded happens to be here and now i
run pca
and true this is the first principal
component now
so if i have one corruption the first
principle component are completely off
they may be completely off
right so one thing we don't talk too
much when we talk about statistics when
you teach multiverse statistics that
really principal component is very
sensitive to outliers
it's an l2 technique so it has to be
sensitive to outliers
and the problem is that now when we deal
with big data
high dimensional data sets we cannot
ignore the fact that we're going to get
many problems like this why because if i
work in computer vision
i have occlusions that introduce some
sort of errors
if i deal with sensor nets sensors will
fail
and so i'm going to have ratings that
are unreliable
and if i deal with other kind of data
again people may
enter bogus entries on purpose
apparently this is a case of netflix
which i'm not going to i think people
know what is a netflix price
but one day i was talking to people
working on the netflix
problem and they told me this they said
that well you know the netflix prize we
get a few ratings
by users about movies and they said you
know in this netflix data there are
entries that are not reliable they are
people who enter bogus ratings on
purpose
and so if you look at the netflix price
and as you know the winning solution is
essentially eighty percent of a low rank
model
is that you get samples now of a low end
component which we think of as being the
true
matrix of users ratings plus a sparse
component
which would be corresponding to those
entries that have been tampered with
so we wish to recover a low rank matrix
from a sample
of corrupted entries
okay all right so now there are other
applications
of the l plus s model
and i mentioned this other group uh of
chandrasekhar and shanghai parilla and
wilsky
the mit group where they got very
interested at the same time about this
low rank plus sparse model
by working on a very beautiful
application having to do with graphical
models with hidden variables a fantastic
line of work
okay so so again we wish to solve this
underdetermined problem
of a very different nature now compared
to the phase retrieval problem
where we have a data matrix again it's a
sum of a low rank
plus parse component and like to
separate both components
and that is well this seems to be a bit
problematic so what do we need first of
all
to make this thing kind of have a chance
to succeed
well these problems need to make sense
so
of course if m the matrix you give me
is both low rank and sparse so for
example if m is something like this
then i this problem cannot make sense i
cannot separate this matrix into a
lowering component and a sparse
component because
well the lowering component could be
this and this parse component could be
zero because this matrix is both
lowering and sparse
right okay
and so if you give me a matrix that
looks like this i could say well the
lowering component is this
the sparse component is zero or you
could say the lowering component is zero
this part component is this
and or half and half and it doesn't
really make sense
and similarly the sparse component
cannot be low angle for exactly the same
reason okay
so um
what is really underlying here and that
maybe we should think about the netflix
problem a little bit so if i
if the rows of the data matrix are users
and the columns are movies
what allows to do matrix completion or
correcting errors is the following that
is
if okay
if i've got the true matrix the true
loren component has two rows which may
be the same by the way
and everything else is zero and now i
corrupt these two entries
or for example i even tell you which
entries i corrupted so you would
you would know that these entries and
this entry are
are you going to be able to impute what
i corrected
right so these are if these are
preferences for movies
and you know there's mickey and myself
there are movies we like
all the rest of you like nothing no
matter what
and uh mickey's rating has been
corrupted for a movie my rating has been
corrupted
how can i impute miki's rating for this
movie i cannot
because what i would need to do is that
we need to use
other ratings that are of people are
similar to mickey and myself to correct
to detect that this is an unusual rating
correct it and impute the correct value
so in this line of work for matrix
completion or
robust pca to work we cannot have
rows or columns that are singular in the
sense that the orthogonal to everybody
else
okay and this is captured by a
mathematical condition
that we worked out with ben rash who is
now here at berkeley
um that i'm not going to discuss but
basically i want just you to get the
intuition that
well if i have a matrix that looks like
this
that have say a pair or a thing a row or
two rows that are singular or similar to
everybody else there's no way i can
corrupt
i can correct corruptions or even impute
missing values it's not possible
because i cannot borrow from the
experience of others
okay so and similarly
if you're very adversarial with me
if you give me a matrix which looks
something like this it's nice because
everybody it's a rank one matrix
everybody looks exactly the same
but if you go out and corrupt the first
column
right you you see x1 you hear it's it's
it's
it's a rating for a movie
and you corrupt all the ratings for
these movies and there's no way we're
going to see whether we're going to like
it or not just we don't even know what
this movie is like okay so
mathematically there is no information
about x1 it's all gone
right there okay so we're going to
assume that in this model that
yes you can corrupt but the corruption
what we're going to do is you can
corrupt so what i'm going to let you is
i'm going to
select to select a fraction of the
entries at random so
you're going to you're going to have
access to a random set of entries which
is of cardinality
proportional to the torum or entries and
you can do anything you want
but i'm not going to let you corrupt
things in a structured fashion like this
all right so so now we've got this
de-mixing problem where we observe the
sum of a low rank and a sparse matrix
and again we don't know much about l we
don't know much about s we don't know
the rank
we don't know how many entries have been
corrupted i have no idea about the
location the magnitudes all that
all of this is unknown
okay and so now to kind of recover this
okay so there's this paper again this
mit paper and
our paper the proposal is identical in
those papers
we're going to try to minimize again do
this by convex programming
so among all the compositions that give
you
the observed data matrix so we're going
to find an l and an s
and so we both want to reproduce what
we've seen
but then we're going to try to favor low
rank
and sparse components and so how do we
do this
well we're going to try to make the
lowering component as low rank as
possible so we're going to use the
convex proxy for the rank
the rank as i remember as you remember
is the number of nonzero singular values
you're just going to take the l1
norm of this so the sum of the singular
values
and for the l1 norm we're going to use
what people use everywhere we're going
to use the l1 norm of
s seen as a big vector okay again this
is a convex
optimization program this is this is a
norm this is another one so i'm summing
two norms i'm convex
in fact it's an sdp
okay so we just do that all right and so
what is the main result so
we solve this optimization problem it's
really completely straightforward know
that i don't know to i mean maybe we're
going to discuss the tuning of lambda
but other than that
i've got nothing i don't need to know
the rank or the number of entries that
have been corrupted or their locations
nothing i just
minimize this and
the result is a bit surprising is this
suppose suppose m is the sum of a low
rank
matrix which is in what we call
incoherent that is does not have rows
and columns that are orthogonal to
everybody else
suppose you corrupt it at the positive
fraction of entry so each entry has the
positive probability of being corrupted
let's say 10 percent then with
enormous probability so it's the
probability is over the locations of the
corruptions
this optimization program when you plug
lambda equals one over the square root
of the dimension of the matrix
is exact that is when you
look inspect the solution to your sdp
the low rank is exactly the truth and
this parse is exactly the truth
okay and this i stated it for matrices
that are squared
if matrices are not squared the result
is exactly the same
the only thing is how do you pick lambda
is one over square root of the maximum
dimension
okay so this is a bit bizarre because
what it means it means that
you have a low rank matrix and then you
start messing around with lots of
entries
selected with location selected at
random you give me this matrix
and i solve this naive optimization
problem
that has no tuning parameter because i
just plug lambda equals 1 over square
root of dimension
and no matter what you did i will get i
will
identify all these locations correctly
re
remove the entries and put back the low
rank solution
okay so it's a bit of a bizarre result
that shows that
i can de-mix the sum of a low rank and
sparse matrix
now when you run this in
in in in practice on
on random problems you see something
like this
so on the x axis you see the rank of the
lowering component
divided by the dimensions so if you see
0.1 it means that the rank is n over 10
and on the y-axis you see the fraction
of entries that are corrupted
which is uh here's like i messed up 20
of the entries and we ran a lot of we
generated random low rank matrices
random sparse corruptions
and then we run the algorithm and we
counted how many times we got it right
how many times we got it wrong
and if we got it right fifty percent of
the time and wrong fifty percent of the
time you'd see a great pixel
but you do not see a grey pixel in this
figure what you see instead
is you see what people call a phase
transition
which is that in this area the algorithm
always succeed
and in that one it fails
and so what that means it means they
have a rank matrix of rank n over 20 so
i would be about here
that is being corrupted what this theory
says is that you can grab about 35
of the entries and still be fine
and beyond that you don't know
okay so now you say well what if you
have corruptions
and missing entries and again that's the
flexibility
of convex programming you say well i'm
going to do exactly the same except that
i'm going to enforce
data constraints only when you give me
samples so now
the problem is really netflix that is
you've got some samples
in blue that are indicated of course
you have some of these samples are
corrupted but nobody tells you which one
they are
so because nobody tells you which one
they are you cannot discard them so you
fit
an l plus s model like this
okay and you've got the same result that
is if you choose lambda to be
whatever it is then then this succeeds
exactly that is
you would actually detect those
corruptions replace them and
and fill in all the correct values
without having to do it really you just
look at l-hat that's all you do
okay so when people use this
to do fun stuff
to do background subtraction so here is
a
it's not our work
okay so this is a video that is done by
group they use this low-rank plus parts
decomposition to do background
subtraction
so you have a video sequence you want to
separate the background from the
foreground
the modeling assumption is that the if i
look at each frame of this video
sequence as a column of a data matrix
the background is not changing so it's
low rank
and the foreground is a sparse
disturbance in this
lowering background and so when you just
apply this l plus process decomposition
out of the box you get something like
this this is a movie from
a not our group but we have movies like
this but this is i'm showing you work of
other people now
so this is a the original scene this is
a lauren component and then it's the
sparse component just picking up the
people moving about
stuff the background
with uh two researchers
ricardo tasso and daniel sodexon
we we apply the l plus s model the l
in a mr dynamic mr sequence that is in a
sequence of
images with time is going to have a
static component which is
well modeled by a low rank element and a
sparse component especially in
angiography
which is well modeled by a sparse matrix
and so we're using this l plus s model
to do
a recovery of the contrast that is
flowing through the veins
automatically from under sample data
okay and so you don't have to do
background subtraction it's all built in
and so on and so with ricardo and
daniel maybe i won't talk too much about
this but
what's interesting so mickey lustig has
been
done fantastic work at promoting the
sparse model
for mr and so now we're looking at the
potential offered by a low rank plus
sparse model for dynamic
mr by modeling
both the static component as a as a
low-rank component and
innovation as a sparse component and
and so i'm no expert in medical imaging
so i would not know how to judge these
images but from what
ricardo and daniel tell me they're
pretty happy by
about the use of the l plus s model to
get sharper
video sequences
okay
if you do not if you have noise again
well you don't enforce
exactly a quality constraint you relax
them
and you have theory that would say that
that you have stability
okay so it's the end of story two uh do
we have questions at the end of story
number two
so i had a question
um was it the case that the locations
the non-zero entries in this pass
component
uh the locations were random but the
entries themselves were
worst case adversarial yes so the
locations are random
but the entries can be adversarial yes
so when you when you prove the theorem
about it that's that's the model right
okay so my my last
uh story about uh convex programming has
to do with super resolution and this
now i'm going to go a bit faster
this is joined with a graduate student
carlos fernandez granda from
stanford ee so
well i'm going to pick up a bit so as
you know
well if i have a point source in the
real world and i'd like to image it
whether i do
astronomy microscopy photography
a point source will not a player as a
point source
it will appear as a point spread
function something that looks like this
everybody is with me i suppose right
okay
and it's because of diffraction
okay so maybe i'll go very quickly about
this
is that if you look at a an imaging
system
there's an object f that you care about
you'd like to image it but you can't
what the microscope can do
it can recover the convolution with f
and the point spread function
and this in the fourier domain a
convolution becomes a multiplication
and so in the fourier domain uh
what this is is you're multiplying the
fourier transform the spectrum of the
object by
the transfer function and so most
optical systems have the following
property that there's a frequency cut
off
and the transfer function is zero after
the frequency column so you do not see
the high frequency
components okay and so
if you look at a camera like the
transfer function would be like some
kind of an
indicator of a disk that have to do with
the pupil of your object
or the the point spread function would
be the so-called airy disk
and so what that means is a point source
will appear like this
on your photographic plate or on your
ccd array
okay right so all right so something
like this
appears something like this when i look
at the distance between the peak of the
transfer function as the first zero
crossing it's called the rayleigh
distance
introduced by lord rayleigh and so
roughly speaking the physical
interpretation is
this this is i take two point sources
and i bring them close and at some point
they will appear just one bump not two
bumps and the distance at which they
appear at one bomb
is called the rayleigh distance
all right so the objectives the super
resolution problem at least this super
resolution problem
super resolution problem people talk
about in optics
is this that is i have a i'm interested
in this i'm
interested in resolving those point
sources
but i can't see them directly i just get
a low pass version of it
and so the problem is to go from here to
here
now i can think about this in the
fourier domain instead
where well this has a spectrum so this
has a fourier transform
which is these wings but because of the
optics
i can only get information about the
lower the low frequency so i get to see
this red part but not this
and i need to extrapolate the spectrum
right so this is really the super
resolution problems extrapolate the
spectrum
now as you can see if i have a
superposition of of
of point sources it has a lot of mass
in the wings it's not a low frequency
object
all right so this is very different from
compressive sensing in compressive
sensing what you do is you use
randomness to undersample the spectrum
but you can do it wherever you want
here you're constrained by physics where
you can only see the central part of the
spectrum so compressed sensing
is really a problem about interpolation
super resolution is very different it's
a much more nasty object
it's a it's a problem about
extrapolation
it's very different cs is interpolation
um super resolution is extrapolation
okay so maybe i'll there are many people
who try to kind of
resolve point sources well if you work
in astronomy
you know you're interested in celestial
bodies so there will be point sources
you have line spectrum speech analysis
fluorescent molecules
in single molecule microscopy and so for
example we work with the work of
the lab of w e merner who is a chemist a
single molecule specialist
and so is interested in imaging single
molecules which are way below the
diffraction limit
so they appear much fatter than they are
and so what you'd like it you'd like to
do super resolution to locate them very
precisely way beyond the diffraction
limit
okay
okay so series is now like the third
problem and the third convex solution
we're gonna look at
and uh and then i'll stop so now i've
got
a signal and i have a superposition of
point sources
and so this i've got objects at unknown
locations with unknown amplitudes
perhaps complex valued
and all i know about this the optics
what the optics is giving me
is giving me low frequency data about
these objects so all i can measure
are the first fourier coefficients
of this signal right so i measure in
each coefficient i have
is a low frequency for a coefficient of
this
and so that's all i get to see and
because
i've got a frequency cut off so i can
only see those wave numbers below
a cut-off location love rayleigh comes
in and it says
emmanuel you do not have the right to
think about a resolution be
which is below one over the frequency
cutoff this is the rayleigh distance
there is no information beyond this
limit in the data set
yet we would like to go beyond because
we need to resolve
this sources beyond the diffraction
limit
okay so here is what thing you might see
in practice
this is a convolution of um
point sources with the sync function and
so now i'm asking
where where are the sources is a problem
you need to solve
and while the left plot has three
sources and they were here
and the right had seven and they were
here and that's what you need to do to
go from the blue curve to
the location of this of these sources
okay and of course here you see
something like your reality business
now how do you gonna do this you can do
this by algebraic method but it's a
lecture about convexity
and convex methods so we're going to do
this
in by convex programming and what we're
going to do is we're going to do
something extremely simple
we're going to use the l1 analog but in
the continuous world
so i'm going to use the total variation
now the total variation of the
probabilities the
metrics they use to measure distance
between distribu probability
distributions
and so all i'm going to do is i'm going
to try to say well i've got few fourier
coefficients
about an object which is like this like
like this
think about really what we're looking at
is if these were not trigonometric
polynomials but just
moments it's like how do you recover
measure from its moments
it's really the same thing
okay all right so
you give me a few trigonometric moments
or a few moments of this measure x the
sine measure x
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try to find that measure with minimum
total variation
and the total variation is is very
simply defined
is simply well what is a total variation
of a sum of amplitudes
point mass at delta tau j is simply the
sum of the amplitudes
so it's really i'm going to go a bit
faster now it's really
in the continuous world l1 it's a
continuous l1
and if you give me noise well i'm going
to trade off between data fidelity or
perhaps with the log likelihood term
and this l continuous l1 norm
okay so now you you have this
and the the the result is
is this is like here is your third
convex program
and the result is is this is as well if
the spikes
are separated at a distance which is
twice the relay distance
then this optimization program that just
simply minimize the tidal variation that
does not know that you're actually
searching for
a sparse spike train is finding exactly
the right spike train
so the theorem with carlos says if the
spikes
are separated by twice the rayleigh
distance
then this convex optimization gives you
the right answer
so it's going to locate from just a few
moments
from data that looks like this the
location of these spikes
perfectly
all right so now you'd say well but how
do you do this because now you are over
the continuum
so now you have a continuous
optimization problem to solve how can
you
implement this on the computer
okay and uh maybe i'll skip my stuff
i'll just that would be
it so what you want to do is you want to
minimize the
total variation norm subject to equality
constraints
this is a convex program but the problem
is that now the
stuff you're looking for is infinitely
dimensional it's over the continuum
so you're going to do this you have
finitely many constraints
but the unknown object has infimum
in infinitely many variables
well every program has a dual and
the dual of this thing is something like
this
what you want to do so it's think of
it's really like duality linear
programming what we're doing really
we're not doing anything fancy
the dual of this optimization problem is
you want to maximize the real part of
the
dot product between the data vector y
and a coefficient vector
c so your dual optimization variable is
c now
subject to f n star the adjoint of f n
less
than one so now what does this mean
physically it means that i need to find
the coefficients of a trigonometric
polynomial
c such that the correlation between
these coefficients and the data vector
is maximized
right that's a dual now when i do this
it's um there's conservation of
difficulty because
well i had infinitely many variables now
the good thing in the dual world is i
have it's a finite dimensional problem
but i have infinitely many constraints
now it turned out that there is a result
which is essentially a result
of kalman i believe and popovich and
others
that this is actually semi-definite
programming with sdp representable
right so searching for
the set of coefficients c such that the
trigonometric polynomial with
coefficient c
is in magnitude less than one over the
whole
interval zero to one has a semi-definite
programming characterization and
i think it works again it goes back to
the work of kalman
it says that it's equivalent to this is
that there's a matrix q which is
hermitian
such that the matrix q c c star one is
positive semi-definite
and q has additional structure its trace
is one
and it sums when i sum q over all along
super diagonals they vanish
so now how do i can solve the super res
problem
i just do this
well the dual problem is formally
equivalent to this it's exactly the same
as this
it's now it's a finite dimensional
problem i can use cvx for my
colleagues michael grant and steve boyd
okay so i just solved this sdp
and i get a trigonometric polynomial c
and i look at it and when the
trigonometric part takes the value plus
or minus one this is the support of the
signal
by complementary slackness and so if i
want to recover the spike locations i
just look at when this trigonometry
polynomial takes the value plus or minus
1. this is exactly the support of the
signal
okay and so when you
work on this in on data so here are
low pass measurements about a spike
train with an snr 14 db
this is a data this is what you would
like to have this is really
a perturbation of the result signal
and now you solve the perturb sdp with
the data feeding term
okay this is where the signal is but
that of course you don't know
what you just get to see is just this
blue curve you solve your sdp
you look at the values where the
triggering rate pointer takes the value
plus and minus one that's your signal
and when you do this uh from noisy data
you can see that when the noise level is
not high
you get a very accurate localization
of your of your spikes of your sources
okay so i want to kind of conclude
saying that
in this lecture what i've tried to
present is i think three important
problems with missing data phase
retrieval
matrix completion of robust pca super
res
that somehow if you you can invoke ideas
from convex programming that make
essentially no modelling assumption
they're model free
and they give you a very good solution
not always a good solution
but often times you get very good
solutions
and then i really sin because i did not
talk to you too much about algorithms
there was a question about this
applications i've shown you just an idea
of what they could be
and there's an avalanche of related
works and so my last slide would be
to try to encourage you to work and read
papers by some of my colleagues who do
spectacular work in this area
i mentioned the great work of the mit
group
for those of you who are working
computer science of course there's a
deep connection between phase retrieval
and max cut
and graph cut algorithms there's a nice
paper by walsberger making this
connection
there's a lot of stuff happening in this
field it's
it's a good area because as you said at
the beginning you can do some theory and
then connect it with applications
and thank you very much for your time
uh people want to ask questions or
so it looked like in the last plot you
showed about the localization
um that the localization was
substantially better than the
estimation of the values because it's an
l1 method so there's a
self-thresholding effect and so yeah
and do you have theory about how well it
does the localization with noise
uh there is if you look at the papers on
noisy super resolution by these ideas
you
see the beginning of it but it needs to
be still
it's in in it's in it's in
it is in its infancy
by semi-definite programming by l1
minimization
um okay so the super so donald has a few
papers
so i mentioned uh so on my backup slide
i have a work of donahoe
here um i i don't think so because i
don't
i yeah but i think it's quite different
though because first of all this here we
are on the continuum
okay so it's possible then i'd have to
look because i know your work very well
uh t times w less than n and so uh but i
was not able to uh
to make a direct connection but with uh
york but
i i might want to revisit this
the the result you mentioned so there so
donahoe and stark so this is phil stark
have a very important paper that kind of
showed what l1 could do
uh in uh in uh for spike
recovery and the model if i work if you
if you allow me was so you had the
sparse spike train
right and then you you had enough you
had um an assumption that says that
if the size of this it was all discrete
and if the side of the support set
times the size of um
the w was less than n or something like
this then l one would work
or squared of n or something like that
there
are several different versions in there
that really i haven't thought about this
in
decades as you know but one version
is like that another version is you have
a
band limited signal correct corrupted on
an arbitrary set of small measure
and you cover with l1 uh perfectly yeah
and then there's also some theory in
there that suggests that
provided the sets are thin so you have
something like sparsity rather than
total measure that it should still work
that anticipates that
donahoe and logan results from the early
90s
right so so i actually have studied
personally all these works so
it seems like when i look at your work
and the work of donahoe with logan and
the work of donna robert himself
which is the work i'm mentioning here
which is the closest well super
resolution via sparsity constraints
there is um in this work there is uh
this is i think in my view the work the
one that comes closest to what we do
because it's really looking at the
problem of super resolution which is
i think a bit different from perhaps
your earlier paper and the work of
donahue so let me mention what it says
the work of donahoe shows the following
that if i take uh
if the density of spike per um nyquist
interval
is assert grows at a certain rate then
the ill conditioning of the problem
grows at
a rate that depends on the density of
spike per nyquist
samples but you have infinite amount of
data if i remember correctly
and um and this is just a a modulus of
calc
of continuity calculation and there was
no
formal proof or formal way of of
saying what happens if you try to solve
the continuum one problem
so but i'm happy to uh go back to your
paper so the work i know is
is the the work of david donahoe which
we refer to extensively in our
paper that looks at the modulus of
continuity for super resolution
where it shows uh contrary to what
people might think
that super resolution may not under
sparsity constraints may not be as
as ill post as people might think
let's take the discussion
thank you again